rico let go of his tail i'm sorry kwami
[Music]
they look so cute and loving and i don't
have any pets so i'm like give me a fur
baby beanie babies who like get rid of
them i don't think i ever had a furby
but i remember just really wanting one
and
really like envying my friends who had
them i was just so in love with them and
they were 70
and we just couldn't afford a 70 furby
oh my god i'm excited oh wow oh wow
look at this sweet little box that is
not how they feel
oh my god is this how soft it's gonna be
look at its eyes oh my god it's so cute
this isn't nearly as creepy as i
remember oh
it's so tender his little feet
look at his little nugget feet this is
always the part that i don't know do you
have to screw back in just yet
[Music]
oh
this now feels like i'm doing something
very bad
is actually kind of annoying so okay
[Music]
hold on just one second i'm just gonna
i'm just gonna do one quick thing cool
okay
oh
my furby's drunk hello
what is it quill
now he came for the pagoda
wake up
so my furby is broken
i'm very disappointed uh so we're gonna
get a new one
i have some uh bad news what
so it turns out these furbies are
discontinued
and i can't find another one
no way
all right so me and my furby are hanging
out um
it will not stop talking
let's introduce some people to my furby
you make a curse i don't know this is
what it says this is its language it
speaks furbish try saying something to
it
so i just turned my furby on at home and
my dog immediately
got up to look for what the hell was
going on my furby actually fell asleep
barbie
do your thing girl everyone else in this
house does their own thing
ouija
it's not even listening to me oh when
you pull his tail he farts every night i
come home to get ready for the next day
i like edit and i prepare for the gym
and this little guy
this little satan thing over here like i
wish that he would wait to be spoken to
like i wish
he's like that friend that interrupt
so today is bring your furby to work day
for me
but this is creepy
[Music]
[Music]
maybe he'll bring yours back to life
wait this is so annoying
i'm happy that i don't need to be taking
care of this
thing i actually had furby in my gym bag
and um he went the [ __ ] off yeah i think
the mask fell off
in the back
so he woke up and he's been talking for
the past 45 minutes my dog and furby are
not getting along he was just biting for
me
oh my god
we're all friends now
[Music]
y'all it has been four days with this
thing
[Music]
i'm feeding him right now oh i fell
asleep
it's the same it's been fun i've learned
a lot with the furby when i was a kid i
really wanted this toy
[Music]
can you stop but now i've realized that
i don't really need a furby in my life
and i'm very good with that one super
annoying but i do love him i'm gonna
give him to my little like nephew so
we'll see how it goes
oh my god it's over
[Music]
you